THE MAIN STREAM MEDIA, OR SO
CALLED.
TIME TO START ASKING WHY.
NOW IT'S TIME FOR SOMETHING A
LITTLE DIFFERENT THIS MONDAY
NIGHT.
POOP AND LASERS?
YES, YOU HEARD THAT RIGHT.
A GROUP OF RESEARCHERS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF COLORADO BOULDER
USED HIGH-POWERED LASERS TO
CHECK OUT HOW FAR AND WIDE WATER
DROPLETS FLY AFTER YOU FLUSH THE
TOILET.
WELL, THE VIDEO SPEAKS FOR
ITSELF.
OKAY, THAT'S GROSS.
THE GREEN IS HOW FAR EVERYTHING
FLIES WHEN YOU USE THE PUBLIC
TOILET.
SO THE DROPLETS AND AEROSOL
FLUMES CAN SPREAD FECAL PERILS
AND CONTAGIOUSS AND SOME SAY,
COVID.
DR. SIEGEL, GREAT TO SEE YOU
TONIGHT.
NOW THE RESEARCH SAYS THE PLUMES
CAN GO UP TO FIVE FEET IN THE
AIR.
OKAY?
HOW DO WE COMBAT THIS?
WHAT DO WE DO HERE, DOC?
>> THE STATE OF COLORADO IS NOT
COMBATTING IT TOO WELL, LAURA.
THEY'RE TAKING, BELIEVE IT OR
NOT, WASTE WATER AND TRADING IT
AND PUTTING IT IN THE TAP NOW.
THAT'S THE NEXT THING.
I CHECKED.
THE RESEARCHERS ARE NOT ON
PSYCHEDELIC MUSHROOMS WHICH WERE
JUST LEGALIZED IN COLORADO.
IT LOOKS LIKE THIS WAS A SERIOUS
RESEARCH.
BUT I DISCOVERED THERE'S 3.2
MILLION BACTERIA PER INCH IN
TOILET WATER.
SO, WHEN YOU SEE IT FLYING UP IN
THE AIR LIKE THAT, THERE'S
BACTERIA, THERE'S VIRUSES, AND,
NO -- YEAH, THERE'S FLU, THERE'S
COVID.
AND, NO, NO MASK IS GOING TO
HELP YOU IN THAT SITUATION.
SO, YOU KNOW, THIS IS A REMINDER
THAT BATHROOMS CAN BE PRETTY
DIRTY.
YOU KNOW WHAT TO DO ABOUT IT?
YOU USE DISINFECTANT WATER.
SECOND THING, HOW ABOUT CLOSING
THE LID BEFORE YOU FLUSH THE
TOILET.
THAT WOULD BE PRETTY SMART TO
DO, RIGHT?
AGAIN, NO MASK WILL HELP YOU.
BUT I THINK THIS IS A REMINDER
THAT ALL OF THIS OBSESSION ON
COVID, RIGHT?
ONLY COVID, COVID, COVID
MUMMIES, THIS IS BASIC PROBLEM
THAT WE FACE IN OUR DAILY LIVES
THAT WE CAN GET PRETTY SICK FROM
THIS.
SALMONELLA, E. COLI, AND
VIRUSES, NORA VIRUSES IN TOILET
WATER.
>> SO MANY STUDIES AND SURVEYS
OF WASTE WATER.
THERE WAS ONE IN MASSACHUSETTS,
I REMEMBER, MAYBE A YEAR AND A
HALF AGO, AND THERE HAVE BEEN
OTHERS DONE ACROSS THE GLOBE
WHERE THEY FOUND COVID IN THE
WASTE WATER.
SO, IT'S THERE.
AND I GUESS YOU HAVE TO FLUSH
AND RUN?
I MEAN, IF YOU DON'T HAVE A
COVER ON THE -- ON THE TOILET, I
MEAN, YOU KIND OF HAVE TO FLUSH
IT AND RUN OUT THE DOOR --
>> ONE HAND AS YOU RUN THE OTHER
WAY.
BUT YOU CLOSE THE LID.
AND BY THE WAY, YOU KNOW, AGAIN,
THERE'S NOTHING THAT YOU CAN DO
TO STOP THE VIRUSES BEING THERE.
AND ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
IT'S NOT JUST COVID.
IT'S BACTERIA.
PEOPLE CAN GET SICK.
ESPECIALLY IN THE PUBLIC
TOILETS, ESPECIALLY SINCE
THEY'RE NOT CLEAN PROPERLY.
>> LAURA: A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T
FLUSH THEM RIGHT ANYWAY.
WE DON'T WANT TO ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE NOT TO FLUSH THE TOILET.
THAT'S NOT THE MESSAGE OF THIS.
>> IT DOESN'T GET YOU OFF OF THE
HOOK BY FLUSHING.
THAT'S THE KEY.
YOU STILL HAVE PLENTY OF
TROUBLE.
>> LAURA: NOT JUST THE TOILETS.
HOT HAIR HAND DRIERS IN PUBLIC
RESTROOMS, THAT MIGHT BE A
PROBLEM TOO.
WATCH THIS.
>> WHEN YOU TURN ON THE DRIER,
YOU VIRTUALLY BLOW GERMS ALL
OVER THE PLACE, ON TO THE PEOPLE
NEAR YOU, ON TO YOURSELF.
THE PLATES NOT NEAR THE DRIER
HAD ONE GERM COLONY ON THEM WHEN
THEY WERE EXAMINED BUT THE
PLATES HAD 18 TO 16 BACTERIA
COLONIES PER PLATE AFTER THE
DRIER HAD BEEN USED FOR 30
SECONDS.
>> LAURA: QUICKLY HERE, CAN WE
JUST STICK TO PAPER TOWELS REAL
QUICK?
>> ABSOLUTELY, PAPER TOWELS.
BY THE WAY, IN FRONT OF THE
TOILET, IT GETS DIRTY TOO.
ONE LAST TIM, YOUR TOOTHBRUSH
MAY BE THE DIRTIEST THING OF
ALL.
WASH IT WITH SOAP, PLEASE.
CLEAR OFF OF THE THE THE
TOOTHBRUSH, THERE'S BACTERIA ON
THAT TOO.
GET RID OF THE BLOW DRIERS AND
USE THE PAPER TOWELS,
ABSOLUTELY.
>> LAURA: DR. SIEGEL, SO HAPPY
TO SEE YOU.